all right so as I rise this morning to
see a trailer for Top Gun I'm like I
don't know if I'm gonna do a video on
that one my friends like wow that it
chapter two trailer right of like
alright let me check that out set up my
camera
let me get to work cuz it chapter two is
one of the movies I'm looking forward to
most this year's of this trailer it had
one job show us that we're gonna get
what we want which is more penny wise
more scares more thrills more gels and
more child death because that kids
[ __ ] yes what bills gonna break
through the glass I call [ __ ] if
bill breaks through the glass one thing
I really liked if this trailer does is
show who the characters are like who
they're playing the adult versions of
because I actually had it in my head for
some weird reason that Bill Hader played
Eddie I don't know why I was like I is
that nerdy quality to them turns out he
doesn't turns out Eddie's played by
Ziggy from season 2 of The Wire which I
was like holy [ __ ]
that kids a time traveler or that actors
a time traveler because I'm pretty sure
that's him from the future good job
casting person good you're you're
crushing it in it chapter 2 oh [ __ ] I
just got with the bathtub is I am a
little concerned that chapter 2 not
gonna be as good as chapter 1 because
chapter 1 was kind of like lightning in
a bottle and they're like oh we got to
do that against and I was on their minds
I've seen that happen a lot with you
know TV shows and granted the source
material for it chapter 2 is laid out
just like it chapter 1 was but even in
the in chapter 1 trailer you see that
slide projector scene which remains one
of the more interesting and innovative
horror movie moments and recent horror
movies for me I haven't seen the scene
like that in the it chapter two trailers
maybe the saving it for the movie I hope
so but I just hope it has something like
that a hook where you're like oh my god
that was interesting that was unique
that was effective good job it chapter
two but we'll see point is I'm looking
forward to it chapter two because I want
to see who took the Revenge of penny was
you're in the trailer penny wise it's
like for 27 years I've trimmed to few
penny wise is pretty pissed and I don't
blame penny wise for being pissed they
shot penny wise in the head with the
power of imagination that'll make a
boggart clown pretty pissed even if the
trailer didn't exist I'd be there to see
it chapter 2 I mean come on at this
point we just the trailers to just here
to show us validation that we have a
reason to be excited for something this
is a great way to kick off Comic Con
anything
trailer for it chapter two until like
Saturday still hoping for a joker
trailer I'd I'm looking forward to my
clowns that's all I'm looking forward to
my clowns of 2019 I don't even care my
favorite part of those trailers but
Pennywise is like just like you see more
bill skarsgård in that scene than you
ever have in penny wise ever it's like
the tinder profile pic versus when you
actually made the person know what I'm
talking about
that should happen alright so it chapter
two the comic-con trailer have you seen
it what did you think about it whatever
you thought comment below let me know
and as always if you liked what you've
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]